people love Terry Crews we have a
picture of him here somewhere there he
is
thank you no napping yeah that's him
taking a nap that's the picture I have
of him on my phone and at 5:00 a.m.
every morning you know you go into work
he's coming out of the gym you're just
like oh I know take a break yeah now you
are changed there's a voice on the Waze
app that helps everybody
everyone in LA uses it now I'm sure a
lot of people in the United States use
it it helps you with traffic and where
the traffic jams are and it has a voice
that comes with it you switched the
voice on your Waze app so that it's
Terry Crews is that right yes someone
tweeted me that was an option and I was
like what and so I switched it to Terry
Crews and the normal lady is just like
turn right you know like turn left
Terry's like oh god it's like jolting I
think we have it listen listen this have
a pleasant drive
[Applause]
very disorienting you're like oh my god
are you sure you want me to have a
pleasant drive you're shouting at yeah
yeah you're screaming at me you you I
didn't realize this your co-star I'm
Brooklyn nine-nine Andy Samberg you guys
grew up together as kids yes we went to
elementary school we had miss
Christianson as our principal I had a
huge crush on Andy and he for some
reason will never acknowledge this when
I bring it up he just deadeyes me but I
used to call his house on like those
old-timey phones that we used to have
the ones that plugged into the wall yeah
like just like I remember those call
those well I'm older than you I had the
old candlestick phone hello walk e55 so
we did back then it's very relaxing yeah
yeah I'm like Terry I was the Terry
Crews of my day I had to be there had to
be so so what did you you would bug him
you would call his house I would call
and hang up Collin hang up as some young
girls do irritating young girls and I
don't know what my end game was really I
didn't have a plan there was no emojis
then that would have made it so easy
emojis would have made it I think when
we just show this picture we have a
picture of the two of you from that era
why is he he's thrown in the back like
luggage I know I know you know that
times have changed yeah I was in the
good seat then well things have changed
countess you been now you said you
mentioned emojis I know that you are a
Europe little obsessed with emojis and
your character uses emojis in Brooklyn
nine-nine yes yes she loves him she
speaks in emojis I'm very partial to
them myself you know the only thing I
will say is like if you text someone the
words I love you and then they write
back with an emoji no matter what that
emoji is they don't love you back does
that mean sometimes it's a cop-out some
really yeah well I think we did you we
have some emojis here I I forget did you
B these are keys that these are I think
you brought these what's like this what
does that mean so this is like flirting
right right this is how it goes these
days okay
I don't you guys I don't I
still have the candlestick phone right
so this you might send like that's
romantic a sunset okay here this is like
oh he likes me saying we're like a
little couple you know okay and then
what's next this is the longer story and
you tell what it is it's a code for
something on the male body is like a
that's not just an eggplant it's an
eggplant but it's inappropriate to send
that as a flirty text because it's very
vulgar I said really I have no idea it's
a phallic symbol ah in today's society I
have no idea I don't I don't have any
contact with emojis
you say you don't have a penis
[Laughter]
the shop class accident
you